Hello, everybody. Two things before we get started today,
one Japanese pronunciations. I'm not Japanese just in case you couldn't tell.
I don't speak it. I am doing my best though.
Second thing is that this episode is brought to you by curiosity stream,
a subscription streaming service that offers over 2000 documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including exclusive original.
You can get unlimited access starting at just $2 and 99 cents a month.
And for our audience, the first 30 days, they're completely free.
And that's just, if you sign up at curiosity,
stream.com/biographics and use the code biographics,
that's all lowercase, no quotes during the signup process. And Hey,
if you're looking for a specific recommendation on me on that platform,
then why not check out something. I recently checked out,
it's called pioneers in aviation. And look, if you clicked on this video,
it's something you're gonna be into and you can even watch it in your free
trial, as well as a whole lot of stuff.
If that doesn't sound like it's right for you, or even if it does,
you can watch a whole bunch else as well. You've got 30 days.
It's also available on many platform. There's a web app, as well as Roku,
Android, Xbox one smart TVs, iOS Chromecast, Amazon fire, Amazon Kindle,
and apple TV. It's also available worldwide. So go to curiosity,
stream.com/biographics unlimited access to the world's top documentaries and
nonfiction series. And like I say, for our list as the pro code,
biographics gets you 30 days free. And here's the thing sponsors like this.
They're an amazing fit. If you like this sort of content,
the content that I make, so you can help support this show.
You can help support me by getting that subscription.
It would be awesome of you and let's get into it.
JRO HRA. Koshi was the most brilliant Japanese
Aeronautical engineer of all time.
He grew up dreaming of bringing Japan into the age where people could travel the
world in airplanes, but he was born in a time when his country was at war.
And the only use for his talent was to make bombers during world war II,
hurricane she designs the famous a six M zero bomber.
This was considered to be the most useful dog fighter of its time.
And the plane would eventually become associated with the infamous Kamikazi on
today's biographics.
We look at the life story of JRO HSI life and the impact that his
creation had on the world.
So before we get into the story today,
we want to do something a little bit different.
I want for you for just a moment to think about the dream that you had as a
child. Now, this sort of passion that we have when we are younger to be,
you know, an astronaut or whatever,
it kind of dies a off as we get older because you know the powers that be want
us to do one thing or there's various obstacles in our way, but for JRO HRA,
Koshi the thing that always felt his childhood was airplanes born in 1903.
Japan was slowly transitioning from living an ancient lifestyle to one of
adopting modern technology that had been created in Europe,
in JIRA's hometown of Fuji.
People were still traveling on dirt roads and using Oxy to plow their fields.
But JRO looked up to the sky.
Sometimes if he was lucky, he could see an airplane flying overhead,
even if he couldn't touch or see it. He knew that there was a whole world in,
out there for him to explore off the islands of Japan.
The idea that a man could fly, it seems like magic,
and he wanted to become a pilot.
However, he was near sighted from a young age and began wearing glasses.
He could not become a pilot because of his eyesight,
but he learns that it was still possible to design planes,
even if he could never fly one.
The only way Jerry could learn more about lines was to find European and
American magazines on the subject.
Japanese translations of these articles didn't exist.
So it'd have to get a dictionary and go word by word through the articles in
order to understand them. Now,
this was the first generation of people in the world to experience electricity
and Japan.
It was still running by candlelight J HHI minds.
It was already traveling the world and it was a earning to respect other
cultures.
At the time.
One of the most respected aeronautical engineers in the world was an Italian man
named Giovanni Batist Proney.
He was famous for constantly pushing the envelope on innovation and testing the
limits of what was possible in airplane design.
The silent film was circulated around the world,
showing cap pro's ridiculous attempt at trying to make a flying boat,
which was a passenger plane with multiple layers of wings.
Even the mayor concept of a passenger plane.
It was incredible at the time because small aircraft could only carry one or two
people.
The idea that something so heavy could fly through the year with dozens of
people inside, it seemed impossible in today's world.
We truly take it for granted how easy it is for an entire family to go on
holiday in a plane with hundreds of other people JRO HRA Oshi,
would've seen Capone's attempts to make magnificent planes.
Capon was truly a legend among aspiring engineers and young JRO began
sketching his childish designs of the planes that were in his imagination.
Luckily for JIRA,
a Oshi Tokyo university opens up a brand new aviation program at their school.
He traveled to a big city to join a group of young men who were just as eager to
learn about engineering. As he was finally,
JIRA had a group of friends who were just as passionate about planes,
and most of them would go on to become his future colleagues in Tokyo.
People were final elite traveling by trains and tram cars.
And the city was a blend of traditional Japanese style and European influences
for a boy who grew up in the middle of nowhere.
This would've been truly spectacular.
He began taking classes in calculus and physics and learned how to elevate his
sketches for airplane design blueprints for a while,
things were really looking up and he was on the path to making dreamer reality.
But on September, the first 1923 JRO was 20 years old.
When Tokyo was struck with the great Canto earthquake,
it had taken Japan years to install all of their modern innovations,
but in only a few seconds, it all crumbled around them.
The trains and trams were derailed from their tracks and buildings were
destroyed. The earthquake. It happened at noon.
So almost everyone in the city was cooking their lunch over an open flame at
exactly the same time. This caused a series of fast arms,
like nothing we've ever seen in modern times.
Thousands of people attempted to take shelter in the army clothing Depot,
only for them to be sitting ducks in the pathway.
They fired tornado that killed 38,000 people.
Since the earthquake destroyed the water mains,
it took two days to put out the flames clouds of black smoke filled the skies of
Japan. And it could be seen from miles away.
The earthquake was followed by a tsunami and several aftershocks.
Thousands of people were dead and nearly 2 million people became homeless.
And just like that, the Japanese were back to living in the dark ages.
What followed. It was a time of great paranoia, racist,
sentiments against Koreans and Chinese people led to rumors that their limited
resources were being poisoned,
which led to the massacre of anyone who was not Japanese without proper housing
or healthcare disease.
It also began to spread when people are struggling to have their basic needs
met. There is no room for higher education or innovation.
This meant there would be no industrial revolution for JRO and the other young
engineers during the far students at Tokyo university,
they scrambled to save their precious AAU engineering books from the flames.
Most of the students though,
they had to bury their friends and their family for a long time.
No one was worrying about studying maths and science.
It was purely just about surviving to live another day.
It would take years for the city to fully recover from the natural disaster.
Many of the original class either died or had to give up their dreams in order
to work, J was fortunate enough to have family back in Fuji.
So they didn't lose everything that they own. When the school reopens,
he was able to return to Tokyo and complete his degree.
After graduating from Tokyo university, JRO HRA,
Koshi got his first engineering job working for Mitsubishi.
When he was 24 years old today,
you might recognize the name of being a famous car manufacturer.
Actor turns out though they've been around since 1870. At that time,
the corporation was called Mitsubishi.
Internal combustion engine company limited.
Their main competition was the Nakajima aircraft company.
And the two were rivals in a fight to win contracts from the Imperial Navy.
Unlike the audacious designs of Giovanni Capron,
no one in Japan was thinking about developing passenger to take people on
holiday.
Obviously the Navy's main concern was making sure Imperial Japan could be just
as strong if not stronger than their enemies for his first assignment,
J HRA Koshi was assigned to work on an existing team that was tasked with
rebuilding the Mitsubishi one MF nine, which had been nicknamed the Falcon.
It was commissioned by the Imperial real Japanese Navy.
A crowd of people stood to watch the Falcon take its first flight only to
witness it completely fall apart.
After the pilot attempted to reach its maximum speed engineering companies like
Mitsubishi, they needed government contracts in order to survive.
And the higher ups in the Imperial Japanese Navy,
they told all of the engineers that they needed faster planes for their ongoing
conflict with China during the second Sano Japanese war,
which overlapped with world war II.
If they did not satisfy the Imperial Navy JRO and his friends would be out of a
job and their nation may lose the war with China.
He worked day and night doing mass and sketching out designs.
Most of the planes created by Japanese engineers.
They were copies of ones that already existed elsewhere.
Creating a new plane design that had never existed before.
Well, it's incredibly difficult and incredibly expensive.
After years of trial and error though,
JRO finally created a blueprint of a completely innovative plane that was worthy
of product. He was 29 years old. This was the Mitsubishi one,
MF 10, and it went into development from 1932 to 1933. It was a mono playing,
which meant that it only had one wing instead of two. However,
after two failed tests,
it was clear that more adjustments had to be made MIS calculations.
Two years later in 1935 J created the a five M and it became the world's first
carrier mono plane. It was revolutionary for the time. However,
its innovation was ignored outside of Japan in an issue of flying and popular
aviation magazine.
One article said Japan's military planes are so poor in comparison with other
powers.
They have not yet gotten beyond milli imitating what others have done someday.
Perhaps the Japanese will have accumulated enough experience in a mechanical way
to catch up, but that day will not come soon,
but actually that day came much sooner than anyone expected by 1940 J began
working on the design of the next model,
the a six M it was dubbed the model number zero, zero,
or simply the zero bomb reached speeds of 500 kilometers per hour.
And it was equipped with two 7.7 millimeter machine guns as well as two 20
millimeter cannons.
It could fly faster than any American plane and it suddenly put Japan at a
big technological advantage over the allies.
When the Japanese Imperial Navy saw the demonstration of the speed and agility
of the zero bombers, they were singing high praises for Mitsubishi's work.
And J's genius mind in China, these zero bombers,
they were completely able to dominate their enemies outdated by planes.
Those by planes, there were simply no match for Japan. However,
none of the Mitsubishi engineers knew about the plans attack on America.
We'll know what happens next.
The United States finally decided to enter the conflict of world war II,
just like IOUs,
the Japanese em empire flew too close to the sun and its resources were
stretched too thin.
But these zero bombers gave the emperor a sense of newfound power for so long.
The allies had a underestimate of Japan, this zero bomber.
It took everyone by surprise. In fact,
even allied intelligence operatives had ignored any information regarding the
creation of J's new airplanes,
because they simply could not believe that little law Japan was capable of
developing such an advanced bomber,
especially when their Aero nautical industry was still.
So young Mitsubishi continued to pump out more and more zero bombers for the
Imperial Navy because they were the only thing,
helping them stay ahead of the Americans for a while,
the us was truly terrified of the speeds and they couldn't keep up.
Eventually the us Navy recovered a fully hack, zero bomber ends.
They were able to examine juror's design and isolated weaknesses.
They realized that the metal on the plane was so thin.
All it took was a few shots to take out the fuel tank and then it would explode
even though they could reach high speeds.
It became more difficult to maneuver and Dodge quickly when it was going so
fast.
The Americans finally figured out how to take down this nearly unstop plane
because of this.
Japan was losing their best pilots and they were forced to send men who had
little to no experience.
Eventually the Americans could easily take down the zero bombers in a matter of
minutes, and there was no time to create and even better plane to replace it.
The only maneuver that gave Japan any hope was the Kika,
which was when young pilots were instructed to commit suicide by flying directly
into American ships at high speed in anti-Japanese propaganda films,
they claimed these men were so brainwashed by the idolization of the emperor,
that they were terrorists, who were willing to go on a suicide mission.
These rumors,
they only fueled the idea that Japanese people were crazy and needed to be
stopped at all costs.
According to one of the Kamikazi pilots who had actually survived saris, Kai,
none of those men were brainwashed and they weren't trying to kill themselves.
On behalf of the emperor.
They were desperately trying to protect the people they loved because they felt
that maybe their own death would help keep others alive.
Sai said, even if you don't tell him to crash into something,
putting a kid with only 20 hours flight time into a plane and telling him to
take on us.
PI pilots is just as much a suicidal tactic as being a Kamikazi.
But let me tell you all that stuff you read about dying for the em embryo that's
all crap. They were thinking about their mother and their family.
Just like anybody else.
In reality Kamikazi was never really a part of J H's plan.
They had actually designed these planes to last for years so that they could be
reused again and again, in fact,
he even incorporated a flotation device to release on impact,
which ensured that the plane would not sink after crashing into the ocean.
He did everything possible to ensure the safety of the pilots.
The idea was to make a plane that was so incredibly fast,
the enemy could not keep up and they could get in and out without putting
themselves in any unnecessary danger, just like with everything else.
It was the military's decision to push men to suicide,
not JS Gerald later wrote in his diary how horrified he was by the whole
situation. When we awoke on the morning of December the eighth, 1941,
we found ourselves without any, for knowledge to be embroiled in war.
Since then,
the majority of us who had truly understood the awesome industrial strength of
the United States, never really believed that Japan would win this war.
We were convinced that surely our government had in minds and diplomatic
measures, which would bring the conflict to a halt before the situation became
catastrophic for Japan.
But now bereft of any strong government move to seek a diplomatic way out.
We are being driven to doom. Japan is being destroyed.
I cannot do anything other,
but to blame the military hierarchy and the blinds politicians in power for
dragging Japan into this hellish cauldron of defeat.
If the war wasn't bad enough already,
there was yet another natural disaster in 1944, a major earth week forced Mitch,
the bushy to halt their production of zero bombers,
which put Japan at an even greater disadvantage against the allies.
Many of the buildings of the factory, they were destroyed the engineers.
They were relocated to a school building while the factory was repaired.
J H Oshi was growing more and more depressed and anxious about the fact that his
planes were causing so much to destruction and that he was indirectly involved
with the destruction of the Japanese empire.
He fell ill with PCY and this forced him to take time off work.
That same year Tokyo and guy were being bombed by the Americans JRO he was too
sick to evacuate. So he sent his five children,
his brother-in-law and his elderly mother to live in his family home in GOMAR,
since it was such a remote farming community, that was far less danger there.
His wife stayed in NA Gaia.
She refused to leave his side and she nursed him back to health.
Why he finally recovered and returned to work.
He saw the damage that had been done to the city in his absence.
He wrote for the first time,
I really feel the effects of the incendiary raids on NA Gaia.
The city is a wasteland char and unspeakably desolate.
My former factory is a ghostly steel ribbed wreck shattered by bombs and
torn apart by the dispersal cruise. It is hard to believe that all this is true.
I knew that soon I would be well strangely though.
I had little desire to return to work the impression of the shattered city and
the wrecked factories will not leave you me after spending only a week back at
work, J H Koshi realized that he truly could not take it anymore.
He didn't want to participate in engineering weapons of war.
His wife accompanied him back to gun Mar where he lived far away from the
violence. Even there,
he could hear the far off sounds of bombs being dropped on Japanese cities.
In 1945,
Tokyo was far bombed and American killed between 80,000 and 130,000 people.
The Japanese people were convinced even more than ever that a sacrifice of a few
men in order to save thousands was completely necessary.
A 22 year old pilot named KHI Gawa wrote a letter to his mother after he found
out that he had been assigned to Kamikazi mission. He wrote looking back,
when I think of you raising me in your arms for more than 20 years,
I am filled with a sense of gratitude.
I truly believe no one else has lived a happier life than me.
I am resolved to repay your kindness.
I always and forever will be living near you together with CZO yes and Nori.
They flew their zero bombers directly into an American aircraft carrier.
The USS bunker hill killing and winding hundreds of men,
even though the deaths of Pearl Harbor and USS bunker hill were a drop in the
bucket compared to the damage that the Americans had done to Tokyo.
The us continued to dehumanize Japanese people to the point where it suddenly
became justifiable to drop atomic bomb on the cities of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki in 1945, killing an additional 129 to
226,000 people Mitsubishi manufactured a total of
10,400 zero. And by the end of the war, they were all destroyed.
Thousands of men were killed in their prime because of the greed of a few
leaders in power J Hari Koshi had to live the rest of his life,
knowing that he was responsible for making the plane that led to so many deaths
in a different time and a different place.
His mind could have been used for greater things.
After Japan was occupied by the allies,
Mitsubishi was forced to dispa its operations in 1947. JRO HRI Koshi.
He stopped designing planes and became a professor at Tokyo university in the
Institute of space. And aortics finally,
he was able to teach his passion younger men who were growing up in a time of
peace, even though they lost the war.
Ger Hoshi proved to the world that Japanese people could invent new and
innovative technology. Just like the Western world.
He lived to see Japan develop into the industrialized society that he had wanted
for so long. In the 1970s, he finally achieved his dream of boarding,
a trans come passenger plane from Tokyo to New York city.
He lived to be 78 years old and died of pneumonia in 1982.
Now that the nation was entering a time of peace,
Japan could finally enter their technological Renaissance today.
When we think of places in the world that have the most advanced technological
breakthroughs and science and robotics,
they are one of the first places we think of in 2013,
the Oscar winning Japanese director, H Miyazaki premiers,
an animated film about JRO Hari's life. It was called the wind rises.
This was the last movie he made before announcing his retirement.
So it became one of Japan's highest grossing films of that year.
There is also a behind the scenes making of the movie documentary called the
kingdom of dreams, madness, Miyazaki. Wasn't just the artistic director.
He also wrote the screenplay while he could find all of the facts about the
sequence of events of JIRA H Koshi life.
That was little known about his relationships or his personality,
HIA Miyazaki's father Kasu was also an AOR engineer by being born just a few
years later,
Kasu was adds the fate of having his designs used as weapons of war in the
moments of the movie where Jerry's personal life was a mystery Miyazaki,
filled the gaps with memories of his father.
He presents the idea that when two people share the same dream,
they are connected in a way that transcends time and space, no matter where,
or when you are born,
they can always understand one another's passion while accepting a reward for
the film on Hari Kosi life Miyazaki said that he was incredibly privileged to
have had a 50 year career during a time of peace,
because it meant that he had the luxury to focus on making beautiful things.
In the end one can see J H Koshi legacy and believe that he is responsible for
thousands of deaths,
or they can choose to see the young boy who had a passion for airplanes only for
the forces of evil to turn something beautiful into a vehicle of destruction.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do leave us a thumbs up below or subscribe, right?
Our fantastic sponsor today was curiosity stream,
which if you like this sort of stuff, you'll really like them. Uh it's.
There's thousands of documentaries and documentary series on that platform.
It's really good. Just try for free for 30 days. There's a link below.
It also helps support this channel. And as always, thank you for watching.
I.